i can now speak to home secretary pretty
patel who has described fellow essex mp
sir david amis as a loyal friend who was
deeply loved by the local mp
morning home secretary um
you were a friend what will be
your memories as to david
i i have endless memories of david um
but he was
he was absolutely engaging and his
energy in particular his energy
enthusiasm passion commitment but also
kindness his absolute kindness to
colleagues in parliament and
i've i knew david for well over around
30 years so that's a reflection of
obviously how long both of us have been
in grassroots party politics
and he was always there as someone that
almost wanted to mentor help support a
sounding board someone that was very
dear and sincere and those are the bonds
that you know in political life when
you're in a political party at the
grassroots starting out
you look i look to someone like david in
particular
and he was a neighbour of mine as well
as someone that would help assist mentor
guide act as a sounding board and you
know he he taught me so much about
conservative party grassroots politics
but also being a good humble
constituency mp
which really was the embodiment and
epitome of david as as we've seen
through the attributes that have really
been shared around um and spoken about
in his constituency as well and i saw
that yesterday
much has been said about him and his
kindness and and so on across the divide
um he he was never a minister
apparently had no particular ambitions
and devoted his career to basildon and
south end
do you think that this
dreadful
killing
is going to undermine the
relationship between mps and their
constituencies
well i think it's a great question
really and it's one that i suspect many
of my colleagues are reflecting upon
right now this weekend um and i've been
in touch with many many um mps
since since this attack on friday
my own view is no
i've always believed i've been a member
of parliament for just over 10 years
and
we are part of the fabric the dna
of society our democracy
freedoms
the chance of people to engage with us
but what i would say trevor is a lot has
changed i've seen that in my time as a
member of parliament i think back to the
appalling murder of joe joe cox
and how that again was a moment of
reflection but also quite an intensive
period for members of parliament
in terms of our own
safety um in our own constituencies and
there's been a lot of work that's taken
place since then um and i know and i'll
say this without going into too much
detail because i think every mp needs to
be conscientious of what they do in
their constituency and how they go about
their business we've all changed our
ways of working
because of changing
concerns threats in society
we for example you know do much more
booking appointments in advance surgery
appointments so so there are practical
things but i come back to actually your
your fundamental premise this should
never ever break that link between an
elected representative and their
democratic role responsibility and duty
to the people that have elected them
to be their representative
if you want to keep that link
alive then
presumably
you may now need to think about
how we keep our members of parliament
and local councillors and so on
safe have you got
thoughts about what we now need to do
because we can't go on like this can we
no we can't we absolutely can't but i
think i think there are two things here
actually one is obviously no question
the safety and security of elected
representatives and yes mps but trevor
you've just said elected councillors as
well thousands of them every saturday um
every weekend actually many evenings in
the week as well we're in westminster
in the week but councillors are out
there every single day
to preserve and protect you know that
very essence of our democracy
we should rightly our elected
representatives need to be able to go go
around with confidence with confidence
that they are safe and secure in the
work that they are doing that's the
first point but alongside that you've
asked the second question or the second
point which is around practical measures
there are practical measures there are
many practical measures and i don't want
to sit here and discuss them all but
for example i've alluded to one already
booking appointments in advance checking
the details of the individuals that you
are seeing checking the locations in
advance that you are going to making
sure you're not on your own i could go
on there are other things linked to
policing and security as well um that
there are things already in place but i
i'm now very much and
lindsay hall the speaker of the house
and i
with the police and with others as well
we we need to close any gaps basically
where where we feel that you know there
are concerns okay well let's think about
how what those gaps might be close i
mean lots of
members of parliament and councillors
try to take those precautions all
already of course but you for example
because of who you are and job you do
have close protection
is it time to consider
making it possible
for
our elected representatives to have that
kind of close protection
that we would enjoy here in westminster
well i th all these all these issues and
options are in consideration right now
so let me just say that there there's a
lot of work taking place already um
there's it's possible
and you know just just this tragic and
appalling attack
there there is a there is a program of
work that takes place around the safety
and protection of members of parliament
in their constituency and that's working
with the police that's all police forces
around the country how they interact
with their mps and how they look after
the mp in their constituency through
various protective measures
the speaker has already put in a range
of measures post friday as we have with
policing but within that there are other
options that are being considered such
as when you hold your surgeries could
you have offices or some kind of
protection while you're holding your
surgery now it's not for me to determine
the mechanism for that right now but
there are discussions underway right now
looking at a whole spectrum that's only
one example and there are others as well
that are actively under consideration
right now so the government would not
close the door and providing resources
for elected representatives to have for
example security and there are there are
resources there already in the system
that would cover so much of this trevor
so this is not necessarily about new
resources but absolutely we will do
everything i'll say this now we will do
absolutely everything to
for me this is and for the government
it's about safeguarding our democracy
and enabling our elected representatives
to carry on
doing what they do serving the public we
are public servants at the end of the
day we are here to you know conduct our
duties in a way in which surgeries
face-to-face meetings all those kinds of
things in our constituency as well as
the work that takes place in westminster
and would airport style security metal
uh arches sure and so on would they also
be under consideration well the that
would be with the police and the house
authorities there there are lots of
things under consideration already
trevor all right well let's talk about
the
perpetrator obviously you can't talk
about specifics
we don't know very much but you have
ordered a review
of mp's security we've talked about that
you also have underway a review of the
prevent program
we already know this man was
in some way
in the notice
on the radar the prevent program but do
you think that there is now a case
this one
the london bridge
something similar for beefing up the
review that's going on as prevent
programme because clearly
it looks as though people are simply
slipping through the net well i think
first of all trevor you've already
touched on this i i can't speak about
any of the specifics and that's totally
not for me to do and that being proper
in light of that as a live police
investigation
prevent is going through an independent
review right now
there's it's a it's timely to do that we
have to learn we obviously constantly
have to learn
not just from incidences that have taken
place but how we can strengthen our
programs the government has a duty and a
responsibility when it comes to the work
that we do and de-radicalization the
type of programs that we put forward the
investments that we put in place to
ensure that the system is working and
let's not forget with prevent programs
channel programs it's not just a
policing component it's multi-agency
social services education health etc so
that is why there is a review underway
right now we want to ensure that it's
fit for purpose robust doing the right
thing but importantly learning lessons
always building upon what is working and
addressing any gaps or issues where the
system needs strength in them i think
it's also important to recognize right
now that there are so many different
component parts around prevention
channel programs and it would be wrong
for us to automatically assert that
people that go through or have a
referral to prevent are automatically
going down the stream of
de-radicalization many of them could
have other factors as well that is the
purpose of this review i understand and
i i don't want to
take you into places where
all you can say to me is i can't talk
about that sure
but
do you have any anxieties that this
thing is not
doing what it
it was invented to do which is to
intercept
and to
anticipate the sort of problems that
we're seeing emerging both
uh the you know the examples of joe cox
and and david amos are the pinnacles or
you know the worst but we know that
there are other
uh examples of this going on
are you not worried at all that this
program is essentially not doing the job
that it's supposed to do i'm not going
to make assumptions right now about the
prevent programme and the work that has
taken place over a number of years
trevor there is an independent review
taking place of prevent right now but
what i would say is absolutely right
through that review program or that
process that's in place that we
constantly learn and we improve and we
strengthen that is absolutely right to
do that is that is why we have the
independent review taking place but on
top of that we have to recognize that
the entire landscape around
radicalization extremism individual
behaviors lone actors it's not binary
it's a complex landscape
and and literally we have to go under
the bonnet as actually our intelligence
agencies do our police do other aspects
of the state do us round case by case to
look at what is going on i get all of
that
but other public figures other members
of parliament might be sitting here this
morning and saying
we're reviewing we're considering and so
on
next week
we are going to put our cells at risk
when is somebody actually going to do
something
well i think how long do they have to
wait how many weeks do they have to risk
their lives so first of all prevent is
going through an independent review so
that's one thing in terms of your
important point the immediate point
around safety and security of
individuals trevor there is work there
is a lot of work that has taken place
already and there is more work underway
friday yesterday today and going forward
with policing in constituencies but also
with the parliamentary
authorities around security of mps and
that is absolutely geared up i should
emphasize this that is geared up around
looking at this weekend and members of
parliamentary in their constituencies
next weekend members of parliament will
be doing the same again out and about
and alongside that what are the
protective measures that we can put in
immediately so this isn't a case of
let's wait for two weeks three weeks
four weeks these are immediate changes
and measures that are actively being put
in place and discussed with mps
what are those messages right now so
first of all what difference well first
of all mps have already been contacted
by their local police forces so that's
600 plus mps around what are they doing
what are they doing sharing information
with the police so that the police know
where they are check in their actual
physical security practice all the
practical measures basically these are
one-on-one conversations that are taking
place and rightly so absolutely rightly
so but with that making sure and giving
members of parliament the confidence for
them to go around in their
constituencies and having that advice
from policing and security as to how to
keep themselves safe let me ask you
about a broader question
which you yourself
in a way uh stand at the center of the
issue of civility in politics
some people have been saying
actually prior to friday but certainly
in the last two days
that
part of what's happened here
is that politics itself has become
quarter that there's
been a language
which homes in on particular individuals
and you yourself have been
i think the subject of
pretty
unpleasant
commentary and attacks and so on do you
think that there is a problem
with politics itself in particular the
house of commons in the way that
mps talk to and about each other that
has produced an atmosphere in which this
kind of violence can take place
well i think first of all
this isn't just about the house of
commerce this is about wider public
discourse and i would also go as far to
say
social media anonymity on social media
where where members of parliament
are subject to some of the most cruel
comments
attacks
um and they are relentless many of them
are relentless i my colleagues go
through just some of the most appalling
attacks i've seen online and i have as
well but trevor you've asked
specifically about the house of commons
i think first of all parliament in the
house of commons has always been
the home for robust debate and that's
how we articulate robust debate views et
cetera et cetera you've asked about the
coarsening of discourse in parliament
i would i personally and i can only
speak from a personal perspective
i always strive to
ensure that i respect colleagues even
when i disagree a political point or
point of policy that may be you know
leveled against myself
but
there are some clear guidance as well
the speaker speaks speaks very strongly
about debate tone how we articulate
ourselves present ourselves in
parliament and i know that every
colleague strives to stick with that and
you know conduct themselves in a in a
decent way and it's decency that matters
and respect matters you refer to social
media just
one word one yes or no would you
consider
uh legislation to remove a right to
anonymity on social media well i i want
us to look at everything and there is
work taking place already we've got a
online harms build that will come to
parliament there's work taking place on
it right now
i've done a lot of work on these social
media platforms mainly around encryption
and areas of that nature
but we can't carry on like this i i
spend too much time
actually
with communities who have been
under attack basically um who've had all
sorts of postings put online and it's a
struggle to get those postings taken
down we want to we want to make some big
changes on that
home secretary thank you very much
indeed thank you